she is grating the coconut with her feet  yeah sure auntie how the coconut I mean  it's such a staple here the land yeah  it's it's it basically means the land of  the coconut right so we have it in  abundance and it's a great cooling  damage yes  I just don't - oh so she's asking you to  go and do it  what's here is it left or right foot  does it matter  no okay here we go  [Applause]  she's making fun of you by the way this  is like the most Awkward yoga pose ever  yeah you might as well sit down  no she think that you've done a good job  enough yeah you know what God  it's obvious now with size 15 feet I'll  never be able to great coconut quickly  man she's good  [Music]